yo what up thinks it's a Greg Alva here
with Berlin from hit or miss movies or
miss movie business in miss movies
everyone says hitter my service well she
is the Miss movies yo there's a legacy
featurette for boy Richard the Carroll
billion everything any of the treasures
I've not seen a single trailer
you haven't seen a single trailer well
we're going to launch you into the
feature wreck called legacy before we do
that though recently launched the
patreon and one of our lovely patrons
Mark Miller Palin says he has a son that
watches hit this channel as well oh this
is a great father and son bonding panel
I'll give you that much you don't want a
father and daughters the women don't
like this channel too much I like this
channel I think I know I think like yeah
you're one of the ten
this is sander Eric Miller they're from
North Carolina Xander Xander Erik that
sounds like Magneto and Professor X
because Xavier Alexander Erik is 92 I
like that you yeah connects I mean wink
Lee Miller Mark Miller writer of chaos
and a bunch of other columns they had
nothing to do then we'll nothing to do
with the Miller part or this is my part
and Savior but cool name man Eddie name
is Virgil Avenger I was just saying with
the next yeah any me McPherson an axe
that's badass you're a badass kid I hope
your dad is okay with me saying the word
ass well we don't know how old he is he
could be you know 17 it's true who knows
or at you before yeah in which case
Martha Miller you are a horrible guy
look what I did
[Music]
sorry happen you have the actual trailer
[Music]
oh wow heart rate rises wonderful
characters caught up in this magical
fantastic world we took the movie by
ride and moving it's about pirates and
combination of those two urges capture
your imagination and became a new
success
behind my support to the caravan
[Music]
drumming Estados x86 Audrey he created a
character who became kind of an icon
anybody wants
[Music]
such fond memories of the frustrating
music on big unveils
[Music]
you are Sicilian to get this feeling or
sensation anything can happen
brother Chad have you ever having it a
little spicy for its movie house new
characters are going to bring any flavor
of this one dimension through one of the
most wonderful fun so please support me
[Music]
this will be so fresh so different so
scary it's a whole reinvention severity
[Music]
yeah I really like the other trailers
for this movie this video did its job
incredibly well because I mean going
over everything I was like you know what
even though I don't really like part
three I especially don't like part four
I really do dig one and do a lot
especially one so and I love you a very
nifty about to go got the defending
whenever I bring up that I really like I
feel like it's on that study decline one
was yeah and then two goes darker and
then three goes really dark and dull
three went to parts where I was like
yeah what's happening on the pirate know
what this is well was showed the ride
and I really appreciate that
that was cool schemes I be like you were
telling me before we film I was about
how people are upset about all the first
of all the Pirates of the Caribbean
movie inclusions in the inclusions
that's a word yeah I inclusion yes guys
the vocabulary that was the last ride
that I believed was still intact that
Disney did himself like he put it
together and he designed it other rides
that he designed had already been like
redone or rushed or something or changed
a little bit but that was the last one
left that was still his original design
so when they put that in people were
like no why did you do that yeah
supposedly that's the story I heard so I
could be wrong
I really let me know every time
someone's wrong you just tell them I
knew yeah I do remember people just
having an immediate kind of backlash
towards the idea of them just I feel
like people get in oil they're like oh
my god their movie franchising the life
changes in general a general set people
will get scared of yeah or just things
that are different
absolutely but what doesn't scare me is
when Johnny debt goes
as Jack Sparrow to Disneyland which he
did this past week yeah before depending
on when this comes out or when you're
watching this and he was on the right
leg in the ride and he was doing some
like monologues and people were like is
that yeah yeah yeah it is
did you and why did you watch the actual
YouTube video hey watch the video I saw
you - I didn't see any like professional
videos that's all about it yeah it's
cool cuz they just new people really
dawg really yes really you have no idea
how many times
Breanna and I have had to make
adjustments on the camera grid there's
one pirate Izzy and now this is that
they did have like camera crews hitting
camera setup or anything they just knew
that people would be recording this and
there was every promoting itself on the
Internet at a movie articles and [ __ ]
because he was just doing a thing for
the fan who's like okay it's like it's a
clever personal you like that you gotta
fourth person yeah he's mad yeah Pharaoh
a lot this is the one thing I like about
Johnny Depp as a person one of things he
also I guess was on the outside of the
ride too like I've been like a trellis
or something like that and Tommy I had a
lunch ago yeah I keep see all these
phones yeah cool what do you see
everyone's phones like does that look of
it anyways well it looks like he's
getting his health back I mean I know
with all those allegations that happened
you know we don't forget you into it but
I remember at that time I was like whoa
China's gained a lot of weight it was
like gain does shit-ton away but now
when I see him and like introduce and
stuff he looks like he's back to a
skinnier healthier version of himself
either way the movie looks like a total
fun thing that one character has got to
be Elizabeth Swann and Will Turner
daughter good you got the names right
yeah and done yeah it looks honest Lee
in this little you know when like a
YouTube video ends and they have like
all the suggested on the video it does
he does look like a girl looks like well
he looks like
and a woman lot yeah wish you were and
of Elizabeth Swann Chilean arrogant is
the real time you can leave the child
18 years in the main they produce the
child for the fifth the ultimate they
reveal them to trailers for confirming
that Elizabeth Swann will be in it a
Lana bloom will turnable be in it I
don't know they're going to be in it
throughout the problem about any credit
yeah this has never been there so we can
put it on the trailer that's what I feel
like their role is going to play is the
son of them then we make a lot more
sense to have them in the film and
something vital in it but as far as a
legacy featurette goes it does get me
excited I'm like you know I've seen all
the Pirates movies I remember how
exciting the first one was and how I
like that was number one at the box
office for like six straight weeks it
was crazy and I remember I went like the
fifth week and the theater was still
jammed acted as a phenomenon launched
Johnny Depp into blockbuster stardom
I've had a huge effect here night I know
right here decades is there and there is
it but but I feel like that was right
heroine like only ejectives spent a lot
of work I remember watching Pirates won
and then you stop slumming it with that
one guy Jimmy yeah I John cynic because
when I saw Pirates won I remember
watching it going holy [ __ ] that's the
guy who played Edward Scissorhands and
Donnie Brasco it dawned on me in the
middle of watching this like something
this guy's done a wide variety of rolled
and he's great in every one of them and
then after this is when decline started
happening with performances but this
looks like he's back I mean I know I
didn't see the fourth one fourth one was
the most upsetting to me primarily
because no not her yeah who's your ruin
oh well not only was the film rather
dull but he seemed like he just didn't
give a [ __ ]
oh yeah it was like that definition of
Johnny Depp is now doing an
impersonation of Jack Sparrow it's been
quite a while since the fourth one by
considering how sequels and franchises
work for big blockbusters like this it's
been quite a while it seems like it
gives a [ __ ] again looking at the
performances in the trailer and stuff
like it seems like he's a lot more
invested these directors come from the
Marco Polo show on Netflix
thrid by Jeff Nathanson who's done a lot
of really funny films so I have a lot of
faith that this one's gonna something to
kill it and yeah I have invested for
movie than I'm going to watch this one -
right I'll probably still not see the
fourth and probably DeBakey that's what
I do I skip around I start in the middle
sometimes yeah it just depends on the
franchise really you know I don't really
touch on this too much when I've seen
the other trailers but Javier Bardem I
don't know it seems like you know
pirates so to me it doesn't seem like a
doesn't seem that stand out like this we
might need that unique to me however I
feel like the target writer Deb he's
probably going to do something
surprising with the role that will that
will be a lot of fun so I can choose the
scenery is crazy-looking makeup anyway
let's move on with our lives
I'm Greg subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell do two
things to make sure you're notified
because if you just subscribe it does
nothing
I just increases the sploshy subscriber
down apparently that's why we get these
views and bought ellipse people and
friends is on miss movies on YouTube
miss movies on Twitter but don't get it
confused with her Instagram and snap
yeah those are different it's miss
underscore movies sorry you get that
correct
okay make sure to follow everywhere ms
movies dotnet has me all me all the time
what do you know how my network with
Duncan yeah I was a weaver calm I didn't
know yeah alright stuff there oh you do
yeah
what's Brienne I'm learning new things
about you every other month it's
shattered again to Zander Griffith put a
mark Xander cage good luck yeah yeah
named for me about how many kids in
school call use an or case you if the
name of your friends and school watches
have them call you Xander cage it's a
cooler name then Eric well that's my
therapist named Eric cool I will tell
you his last name but it kind of sounds
like a Nemiroff name